c'est ici qu'elle travaille dans cette
ville secrète ce monde apparaît sous
votre surveillance
emmanuel est la seule femme en france
officier de marine aux commandes d'un
remorqueur sur la base navale de toulon
elle participe à des missions délicates
comme le retour du charles de gaulle à
quai j'ai limité la casse justement
assez freiné le bateau en plus possible
pour que l'impact sur pas 3
avec emmanuel et théo un jeune matelot
nous découvriront les coulisses de ce
monde secret
imaginé par vauban il ya plus de quatre
siècles et qui ne cesse de se réinventer
plus à l'est sur l'île de porquerolles
rendez vous avec édité marque free les
il restera avec passion le fort du petit
langoustier
[Musique]
ralentis et mettons à tribord
un ancien fort militaire du xviie siècle
une restauration à leur image éthique et
éco responsable
on récupère tour est
un défi de taille pour ce couple
téméraires surtout en hiver car le fort
n'est accessible que par la mer
et c'est pas facile est ce qu'il fait il
faut se battre tous les jours pour y
arriver
mais pour commencer direction la rade de
toulon
5 heures du matin
emmanuel parce que les contrôles pour
pénétrer dans un monde interdit au
public l'un des lieux les plus sécurisés
de france
ce capitaine va vivre aujourd'hui un
moment magique un événement
extraordinaire qui fait rêver toute la
rade
c'est toujours beaucoup de préparatifs
et un petit peu de tension un petit peu
de préparatifs un peu différente de ce
qu'on a l'habitude de faire
c'est une manoeuvre qu'on fait pas
souvent
c'est une manoeuvre qui peut être
dangereuse aussi bien moins de personnel
que pour le matériel donc c'est une
petite pression supplémentaire
sa mission ramener le fleuron de la
marine française à bon port accompagné
de son escorte le charles de gaulle fait
route vers toulon son port d'attache
emmanuel est aujourd'hui la seule femme
en france a commandé un remorqueur
allez olla partout leurs portes ou quai
mais quand vous montez
sous ses ordres ce matin ces six hommes
un petit rappel sur la manoeuvre
attention à la au moment de l'impact sur
la coque du charme ce qu'on va dire on
vient toucher et après dans la foulée
tout de suite il faut il faut venir à
cros celle haussière c'est bon
rien ne prédisposait ce premier maître a
ramené l'unique porte-avions français
moi je viens du doubs
en franche comté
donc où la marine n'existe pas ou il n'y
a pas la mer
moi je voulais être marin
dans un ballet parfaitement organisé
cinq remorqueurs vont prendre en charge
le géant plus tendue que d'habitude
le premier maître a rendez vous à cette
heure précise
à l'entrée de cette petite rade
[Rires]
balla gaye pouvait déjà pas pensé à vous
rapprocher de look
vous plaisantez
soudain le porte avions fait son
apparition deux milles marins rentrer à
la maison
[Musique]
été affecté sur le charles de gaulle
pendant trois ans il ya un peu plus de
dix ans qu'on soit équipage sur le
charles de gaulle et soit patron de
remorqueurs pour remorquer le charles de
gaulle c'est quand même toujours là un
petit peu l'impression
à la mer c'est une mini ville sur l'eau
on va dire
puis quand même 16 mètres pour atteindre
le pont d'envol donc ça fait quand on se
présente c'est
c'est toujours un petit peu
impressionnant
[Musique]
la manoeuvre délicate réclame
concentration et coordination le premier
danger c'est la puissance d'aspiration
de ses 42 mille tonnes d'acier
emmanuel doit viser juste au dessus de
ce repère pour s'amarrer aux porte
avions représentent
une fois qu'on est dans ce phénomène
on a plus on n'a plus la main sur nos
sur notre offre sur d'autres et là on
est obligé de se laisser de limiter la
casse justement a essayé de freiner le
bateau plus possible pour que l'impact
soit pas trop important
[Musique]
le plus doux d accostage jamais réalisée
par emmanuel soulagé
ok
allez dès que tu peux et qu'ils ont
dégagé que tu reprends es tu monte à 150
la manoeuvre est réussi en tout cas
désormais c'est elle qui assure la
propulsion de ce symbole de la puissance
nucléaire française
reste à sécuriser le géant l'a mené vers
ce qu'est spécialement construit pour
lui
et cette fois encore ça se joue au mètre
près
des fois à 50 cm
d'autres précisions pour
261 mètres cinquante exactement
si à cette question emmanuel ne sait pas
répondre à d'autres elle ne faut pas
répondre
secret défense
il rentre de quatre mois de mission
monargent 2
[Musique]
au large
pas le temps de s'attarder il faut
maintenant ramener le forbin
rouge environ huit heures le forban de
même revoir ce sens m
cette frégate de défense aérienne a
accompagné le charles de gaulle tout au
long de sa mission
au son du bagad de saint mandrier
emmanuel va permettre les retrouvailles
de ses marins et de leurs familles
on est marin on sait ce que c'est que de
naviguer de partir plusieurs mois et de
rentrer c'est des moments qui sont
importants pour les marins aussi les
retours de retrouver leur famille donc
par tino participé aussi à ça
[Musique]
c'est on
ne voit toujours pas
venu spécialement de nîmes pour
accueillir son jeune matelot cette
famille pour l'occasion et pour la
première fois pu pénétrer dans la base
navale papa et maman à temps de leur
fils unique on est venus en force pour
le retour de nos marais voilà après
quatre mois de mer ça fait plaisir de
les revoir en fait quoi
ça a été difficile il a que 18 en deux
voies là
on a vu des nouvelles quand même il ya
des moyens de communication et on savait
où on avait des nouvelles cités mais où
caisse a duré trop longtemps c'était un
peu difficile heures c'est déjà ça fait
une semaine qu'on n'a aucune nouvelle on
aimerait savoir mais bon pour l'instant
je n'ai pas vu donc
ça m'embête un petit peu
les officiers descente en premier les
macklowe eux se font désirer
oui
et dans ce cadre là
[Musique]
c'est sa première mission engagée depuis
un an dans la marine théo débarquent des
étoiles plein les yeux
[Musique]
c'est incroyable des pays des pays qu'on
n'a jamais vus c'est une expérience
unique j'ai quatre continents en quatre
mois j'avais j'avais jamais quitté
l'europe
voilà j'ai jamais vu ça et voilà j'ai
hâte de repartir et même si on vient
d'arriver on va profiter de la famille
mais on va partir et l'a rapidement
[Musique]
moi c'est moi je suis dans ma vocation
n'y a pas de souci
et cela fait 400 ans que des vocations
nestea 6 400 ans que la marine nationale
fait vibrer toulon
au coeur de la ville 22km d'hockey
accueil plus des deux tiers de la flotte
française l'une des plus puissantes au
monde
des bassins des casernes et même une
pinède descendu par de hautes murailles
rien n'est visible depuis la ville et
pourtant le lieu est immense vingt-trois
militaires et civils y travailler chaque
jour
[Musique]
c'est aussi le premier site industriel
du bas 20 ans qui manuel r comme ses
quais et elle s'y perd encore je connais
tout ce qui est maritime les quais les
choses comme ça après l'intérieur de la
base et tout ce qui peut y avoir la base
non je pense que je connais pas je
connais pas toute la base
4 lignes de bus une chapelle qui est
aussi mosquées et synagogues un centre
médical une agence de voyage et il n'y a
pas si longtemps encore une salle de
cinéma la base est une véritable ville
dans la ville
elle a traversé les siècles sans cessé
de se réinventer et vit 24 heures sur 24
7 jours sur 7 c'est le plus grand port
militaire de rome
pour s'en rendre compte il faut prendre
de la hauteur
enfant du pays rémi kerfridin a parcouru
la rade en tous sens l'histoire commence
au xviie siècle quand henri iv décide
d'y baser ses galères
cette rade pour voilà
avec l'isthme des sablettes et sam
envoyé ça fait jamais que quatre cents
ans qu'on a ce qu on va se ce paysage et
avec cette petite art voilà donc est
complètement fermée évidemment c'est un
abri naturel
louis xiv rêve d'une flotte de 60
vaisseau en méditerranée
séduit par cette rade fait pour la
défense protégées naturellement
contrôlée houle du large vauban son
architecte désenvaser modernise le port
pour en faire un grand arsenal
à l'époque sur le plan romand on a quand
même presque 70% de l'emprise urbaine
qui est destiné à la marine la priorité
c'est que tout le monde soit encore ce
français de guerre sur la maternelle une
décision une volonté qui a duré pendant
des siècles
la ville vite au rythme de la marine
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur ce que vous avez les
identités s'il vous plaît c'est bien
vous monsieur passer une bonne journée
d'angoissé aux amples et pour passer les
portes de la base il faut une
autorisation spéciale rémy l'a obtenue
il ya 15 ans et en connaître tous les
secrets
il a le privilège de promener son carnet
de croquis sur ses quais auteur de
l'ouvragé référence sur l'arsenal
passionné il apporte une poésie à ces
bâtiments gris
[Musique]
on va découvrir que même pour les
toulonnais n'ont pas accès à celui là
et pour les militaires qui sont pas
sales aussi disposent parfois des
questions sur les endroits où il courait
[Musique]
pourtant il regorge de trésors
soudain on dirait les tropiques
ces jardins de l'astrolabe est le
dernier témoin de la grande époque des
expéditions coloniales
en fait il ya un certain nombre d'arbres
qu'on connaît nous maintenant qui porte
le nom de ses expéditeurs français
magnol a donné une mamie la scientifique
qui était sur dur avec dumont d'urville
et bougainville le bougainvillier au 19e
siècle de plus en plus d'équipages
arrives tu à toulon il faut les loger
c'est l'âge d'or de l'arsenal
[Musique]
et on y allons
donc c'est l'art c'est là que ça va se
faire
remarquable c'est une surprise quand on
y entre cantons ont fait un travail sur
le patrimoine c'est de voir qu'il y a là
des formes urbaines et enfin des formes
d'architecturé
sont en bon état en état d'origine
essai de conservation a pu se faire pour
espérer en prof mais parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de pression foncière à ce
moment là
préserver de l'appétit des promoteurs
grâce à la marine ce patrimoine unique
au monde raconte l'histoire maritime
depuis le 16e siècle
au coeur de l'arsenal vauban créé un
chantier naval pour faire de toulon le
1er port industriel de france mais
comment réussir à travailler sous les
coques de navires dans cette
méditerranée sans marc et son ingénieur
naval antoine rognard à une idée de
génie c'est qu'elles sèchent nommé
qu'elle de radoub permettent de
travailler à 15 mètres sous le niveau de
la mer
à l'époque les forçats pompes 24 heures
sur 24 pour maintenir cette enceinte à
sec
là on est à la proue la première cale de
radoub les bassins grognards qui a été
entièrement réalisé par les bagnards en
1776 78 les bateaux
entrée par cet endroit et venez poser
leur nez ici dans cette forme qui
étaient conçus spécifiquement pour ces
bateaux comme bois de l'époque des
vaisseaux frégates et autres
une idée si ingénieuse qu'elles
fonctionnent encore aujourd'hui dans
laquelle voisine de 400 mètres de long
le chevalier paul se refait une santé
une fois le navire à l'intérieur ce
bateau porte est immergé comme un sous
marin il permet d'assécher le bassin
[Musique]
bon
les réparations terminée il suffit alors
de le remplir grâce à ces surpuissante
pour mécanique
après neuf mois de chantier le chevalier
paul peut ainsi regagner le large aidé
par le premier maître emmanuel et son
remorqueur
[Musique]
dessinateur d'assises habitué à croquer
sur le vif des portraits lors de procès
à huit clos rémy n'en perd pas une
miette
systématiquement jardinier jour son
destin
je n'ai pas bien vu mais de ce que j'en
ai fait j'ai l'impression que ça m'a
donné aussi
une bonne quinzaine d'années
tirer sens
spectateurs privilégiés l'auteur dévoile
les coulisses de ce monde clos
une de ses plus belles découvertes se
trouve à 200 mètres à peine de
l'autoroute
ici l'explorateur a découvert un secret
encastrée dans ses remparts du fort mal
bousquet
[Musique]
sous 15 mètres de terre un dédale de
souterrains abrite un témoignage
étonnant de la fin de la guerre ces
galeries raconte l'histoire des hommes
qui ont vécu après la libération de taux
longs en 1944 voilà donc là on arrive
dans la partie basse de la galerie
avec
la en est à
une première cellule
et
on découvre
un véritable petit décor de bavière
assez bien réalisé avec une jolie s'est
fait non alimentaire
est ici
en fait voilà encore une autre
une autre un autre décor d'un
tipi que de la bavière natale des
des prisonniers
retenus dans ce fort devenue prison
disciplinaire ces événements ont le mal
du pays
voilà
un peu comme car postal et nous avons un
petit une petite phrase en allemand
acmat temps y voient là une manne qui
est un peu l'équivalent de home sweet
home
[Musique]
il ya 83 cellule décor et il y avait
plus de 400 prisonniers la deuxième
guerre mondiale
les allemands qui étaient prisonniers
ici ont été retenus prisonniers en fait
en partie pour faire la reconstruction
de toulon et ils étaient employés
particulièrement une personnalité le
déminage des anciennes partie de la base
[Musique]
ces fresques ne sont pas accessibles au
public et l'histoire de la base est bien
gardé
pourtant si l'on embarque une tradition
toulonnaise permet d'en découvrir une
partie
vous amène alors vous avoir le charles
de gaulle allez-y on va partir de trois
minutes
bateliers de la rade comme son père et
son grand père bruno menly promet une
vue imprenable sur la majeure partie de
la flotte française à condition de
respecter des règles précises il ya très
longtemps les anciens bateliers à
l'époque qu'ils avaient quasiment aucune
des bateaux pour lundi vraiment à 20
mètres des bateaux j'ai connu ça va m
mehal et 50 mètres et après on a fait la
sécurisation de la base avallon nous ont
fait reculer gentiment
les normes concentration de navires
militaires fait de tout une cible de
choix et voici le clos de la balade le
charles de gaulle le quai le plus
sécurisé de france dans les boules qui
longtemps sous l'eau c'est un barrage
anti attentats et sous les boules il y a
des filets métalliques et qui pendent
jusqu'au fond de
c'est ici que commence un espace sur la
mer interdit aux toulonnais attention à
ne pas franchir les limites de la zone
militaire sinon
qu'est ce qui se passe il ya les
commandos qui vont venir de suite nous
voir pour nous faire ressortir de la
zone interdite à nous au pire acier
d'ailleurs peu importe les bateaux
[Musique]
armés jusqu'aux dents lucas et thomas
font partie des 450 fusiliers qui
protège la base des attaques venues du
large leur mission identifier un danger
parmi la quantité de navires qui
circulent dans cette petite rade pas
simple car ici se croisent baigneurs et
sous-marins
les jours il ya trois-quatre corsica qui
viennent faire les allers-retours
corso toulon et ça se partage comme ça
et des fois vous avez des bateaux
militaires qui sortent en même temps des
sous marins
aujourd'hui pour se protéger d'une
éventuelle menace terroriste venu de
méditerranée la marine renforcent leurs
moyens ça fait maintenant quatre ans
qu'on a équipé de gilet pare-balles deux
fils d'assaut la cela on les a eus
récemment la schl 416 c'est sûr qu'ils
aient une réelle montée en puissance web
à
terre aussi pour faire face à cette même
menace les marins d'aujourd'hui se
promènent incognito et se font invisible
pas un bashing dans les ruelles du petit
chicago l'ancien quartier des marins le
fameux béret au bond pour bouge semble
avoir déserté la vieille ville
[Musique]
pour voir des uniformes il faut se lever
tôt et regagner la base
[Musique]
7 heures théo le jeune matelot arrive en
civil comme tout l'équipage du forbin
[Musique]
nouvelle réglementation oblige les
marins revêtent leur uniforme une fois à
bord
vous portait pas l'uniforme en ville non
c'est interdit quoi de porter l'uniforme
en vie pourquoi parce que on peut subir
des pressions de la part de certaines
personnes
depuis les premiers attentats de 2015
cinq ans les attaques contre les
militaires se sont multipliées
l'uniforme est proscrit en ville
pas question pourtant de ne pas
respecter le protocole pour théo et les
200 marins de la frégate
[Musique]
s'engager pour représenter le pays pour
pour le défendre pour là on est dans la
force militaire donc ça fait toujours
plaisir un même qu'en partie couleur ou
jusqu en est quand on y assiste et bien
c'est un sentiment de fierté qu
[Musique]
à 16 ans théo arrête ses études il
découvre la seule armée avec une école
pour mineurs ils s'engagent fait l'école
des mousses et sa vie on est bouleversé
je vais en 1800 euros par mois à terre
et après pendant dix ans a commenté
c'est une bonne rémunération quand on
n'a pas de diplôme et un individu
ça m'a permis de prendre un appartement
alors que j'avais 17 ans d'être
indépendant
voilà ça m'a fait grandir tout
simplement
j'aurais jamais exxon en civil ou chez
moi à nîmes j'ai découvert une nouvelle
ville je connaissais personne ne
connaissait rien du tout je suis arrivé
j'étais seul jeu on dit tu montes sur ce
bateau outre le bateau comme ça et
apprend ainsi fait et ça marche bien
à bord du forbin théaux s'est enfin
trouvé cette frégate dont les radars
peuvent porter à 4000 km rentrer de
syrie où elle a poursuivi la guerre
contre l'état islamique tu es aussi
spécialiste comme technicien d'armes
on est devant l'as où tu là la sto
munitions dévastèrent donc il y avait un
cercle et des missiles aster 15 aster 30
qu'un pour 15 des 30 nautiques en fait
de porter
non
[Musique]
quand cette alarme retentit l'apprenti
artilleur à 2 minutes pour rejoindre son
poste de combat un lieu secret au coeur
du navire où nous avons été
exceptionnellement autorisés à filmer
c'est ici que se sont donné les ordres
de tir
si jamais elle menaçait je me dois de la
neutraliser avec l'aide de canons de 105
mm à l'avant
on
passé en stand by
selon son supérieur il va pouvoir
bientôt être lâchés en langage de la
marine théo a le permis de tirer
je tire au canon
je lui tire en exercice c'est incroyable
oui c'est les huit ans et des
responsabilités que dans le civil
j'aurais jamais l'opportunité d'abord
c'est pour ça que voilà je suis
redevable à ce métier c'est pour ça que
c'est exceptionnel en fait
et je sais que mon pauvre le feu à tout
moment même dans les missions les plus
les plus simples et je sais qu'il ya
toujours un risque quand on part en fait
que que quelque chose qu'un conflit se
développe en ondes dès qu on soit emmené
en fait
en attendant de rejoindre une zone de
guerre où il n'aura pas le droit à
l'erreur théo continue d'apprendre son
métier de marin et le quotidien c'est
l'entretien du navire et la discipline
ordre du jour vérifier ses cales d'où
sortiront les missiles
c'est vrai qu'ici c'est une fois savoir
obéir faut savoir encaisser les les
remarques la réflexion voilà c'est pas
ces panneaux n'at-on
comme théo la marine forme chaque année
3500 marins à quelques quai de la
emmanuel a rendez vous dans un lieu
incontournable de la base
c'est l'heure de la virée shopping
derrière cette porte les marins trouve
la fierté et le rêve ici les carrières
se concrétise l'uniforme c'est tout le
prestige de la marine
aux petits soins ces couturières
toulonnaise habits 28 milles marins à
tout le monde et dans toute la france
grâce à l'intranet voit la jeune fille
non combat des galonnés
airs galonnés un quartier maître en
première classe
dites moi qu'est ce qu'il vous faut
médailles
le premier mettra besoin d'une nouvelle
tenue bonjour progrès qu'est-ce que je
peux faire pour vous
allez venez avec moi on va faire un
d'essayage
laurent chef du magasin c'est le karl
lagerfeld de la marine française
baisser les bras
je vous faire passer en cabine et je
vous laisse essayer
il ya la tenue de travail et il ya la
tenue blanche de l'effet d'une forme de
cérémonie la tenue bleue il ya ce qu'on
appelle le panache et c'est à dire la
chemisette blanche avec un pantalon bleu
ou un pantalon blanc et après vous avez
ce qu'on appelle les t4 s2c les tenues
de combattre qui est
tenue similaire à l'armée de terre donc
le marin à son sac complet il lui faut
de la place parce que ça représente
beaucoup de tenues beaucoup de
chaussures la mariée dans le général a
toujours été bien habillé
6 heures le premier port de guerre
méditerranéen est en effervescence
sept navires largue les amarres ce matin
dans ce supermarché où transitent chaque
année 18 millions de tonnes de vivres on
prépare l'avitaillement des navires de
l'alimentation énergisantes pour
commando aux croquettes pour les chiens
des fusiliers marins
[Musique]
le tonnerre porte-hélicoptères amphibie
part pour un mois de mission en mer du
nord il faut nourrir les 300 marins du
bord
[Musique]
gare à vous
en payant
[Musique]
emmanuel réparti le travail entre les
hommes de son équipage balagué combien
de personnes
3 4 avec 3 après sur le balaghi bon ça
marche allez bonne journée
oui
à bord du forbin qui cette fois par seul
en mission théo part pour un nouveau
voyage
tracté par un remorqueur où une jeune
maman désir elle aussi parfois d'autres
rivages ça manque un petit peu de plus
naviguer de plus partir de pour faire
des missions quand on est marin quand on
s'engage c'est aussi en partie pour
parce qu'on a que ce qu'on a envie de
naviguer envie de partir et marne
la frégate sorte de la rade emportent
leurs songes vers le large la ville
secrète se referme
[Musique]